[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Derek is
in San Diego hi Derek how are you I'm
doing well Mr Ramsey how about yourself
sir better than I deserve what's up glad
to hear glad to hear um basically I
wanted to discuss my uh current
situation with saving money I'm 28 years
old I make about 105 at my current role
and another 25,000 uh in sidewalk
through flipping items and I am saving
about3 to $4,000 every month after all
my expenses I don't have like a car loan
or anything of that nature and I'm
sometimes I worry that you know maybe
I'm not enjoying life as much as I would
like because I'm just so focused on
saving money and budgeting and
calculating my net worth every two weeks
um so I just wanted to get your guidance
on when you really decide and how you
can tell you know that you need to start
enjoying life more with the money that
You' save one more time you got 25
coming in on a side hustle and what's
the other what's your core
income uh my W2 every year is
105,000 okay so so you're making like
130k with your side hustle correct and
you're saving like four a month okay
cool yes yes I think that's great you
know one of the reasons that we walk
through the baby steps is it kind of
gives you um guidance for each area of
your life and then it also not only the
guidance but it gives you the
permissions to do what you want to do
with your money so in your case if you
have no debt right you have no debt at
all of any kind no I don't have I have a
car that's you know 18 years old do you
have any debt of any kind none none at
all no student
loan uh my father is taking care of that
that's an agreement we
had how much is a student
loan it's uh 16,000 total whose name is
it
in it's uh in my father's and mine if it
if it's in your father's and your
there's no such thing it's either a
Parent PLUS Loan in his name or it's in
your
name I believe then technically is in my
name yeah I think technically it is if
it's in your name you got to pay that
kind of like you're in debt yeah yeah
pay it off like technically okay so how
much money do you have saved like how
much money you have St
side uh we save right now now I have
about
130,000 and how much is a student loan
16 it's about 16,000 good pay it off
today pay it off today now your savings
is it what where is it is it just
sitting in a high yield savings
account uh I have some in some Vanguard
accounts and then also 401k and about
60,000 in uh two bank accounts okay so
the 60,000 that's in the two bank
accounts pull pull some of the 16,000 to
pay off the loan how much credit card
debt do you have
uh none I just use debit I've been
following you for a long time okay well
sort of yeah so then you okay then you
understand the baby steps so you're are
you already investing 15% or more uh yes
more than that okay where do you live
are you renting are you
owning uh I currently R okay so now we
now that's what I was saying before
we're using the baby steps to figure out
what we should be doing how we should be
spending so at this point if I'm you
instead of overfunding the 15% I'd
probably start focusing on a down
payment because at some point you're
going to want to stop renting you're
going to want to have control over that
biggest line item on your budget right
you don't want to rent forever rent is
going up it's always fluctuating right
so if I were you instead of doing over
15% I would stop that cut it at 15% and
then I would take your extra margin put
some of it to a down payment right
that's baby step 3B and then you get to
decide how intense you want to be about
this right you can decide if you're
going to just go hard in the paint or if
you want to pull back it's like you know
what I'm young I got you know I it
doesn't have to be that intense at this
point does that make sense yeah you're
you're running on gazelle intensity and
now that your student loan is paid off
you don't have to do that so here's what
I would do I pay your student loan off
your dad has promised to pay it I heard
you loud and clear he can pay you
back if he wants to pay it he can pay
you but I don't want this in your name
anymore I want it gone so you pay it off
today so your 105,000 in savings has
been reduced by 16,000 we take a portion
of that and allocate it to your
emergency fund of 3 to 6 months of
expenses the rest of that you can
allocate as a down payment now back to
your question when do you enjoy life um
now now you need to budget some fun in
your budget all you do is save and you
need to have some fun in your budget and
you need to have some generosity in your
budget that you don't have too you need
to be helping some other
people right you make $130,000 a year
you're 20 something years old you don't
have any debt yeah you ought to have you
ought to have some fun and you ought to
save some and invest some and you ought
to have some generosity you got to
always have all three things in your
budget once you're at your stage okay so
for the rest of your life like Derek
when Sharon and I get a check in from a
publisher or something these days it's
extra money we have a formula we apply
to it okay we take out you know 40% for
taxes 10% for TI that leaves 50% now
then um after that uh uh because rich
people pay all the
taxes the tax just let me help you with
that okay but anyway but aside from that
the um so so then we apply the O put the
other 50% goes to three things and we
have a a set percentage for more fun
more generosity and more
investing out of that other 50 okay like
one of my friends does that he puts 30
in investing increases his lifestyle by
five and puts 15 into extra generosity
and that gets you to your 50 okay so you
know you work it out but my point is not
necessarily the percentages or even that
you have to have a formula for it but
you ought to always have all three in
there absolutely and if you have all
three in there then you've got a pretty
good balanced life because once you're
out of debt other than the house which
you are today because you just paid off
your student loan if you really follow
us now and then you put have your
emergency fund set aside once you're
bass baby step three yeah you go from
intense which is what you've been living
to
intentional intentional means we're
investing some additional generosity and
additional fun yeah that's good yeah and
you can so if you've been wanting to
upgrade the dot dot the car that's the
fun cuz his car is old yeah okay you got
you're driving a beater then yeah let's
let's upgrade the car and you probably
have the money to do that above your
emergency fund even after you pay off
the student loan today yeah he will
because he had at least 60,000 sitting
he had 104 oh that's right but some of
it was I think was invested oh well but
was it invested in IRAs he said 401 1K
oh was okay we don't touch that 41 401K
okay okay that's good yeah but either
way either way still still going to end
up being the same thing so good question
sir good question thank you for joining
us so guys
um the the things that we teach they're
they're everywhere I mean you go through
Financial Peace University you get a
detailed line by line thing of okay make
sure what you guys talked about on the
uh uh live stream the other night you
and Rachel make sure you don't have a
$3,000 tax refund right okay adjust that
that's one of the things we teach make
sure you're not sitting on whole life
life insurance make sure you're not
sitting on investments that are non
retirement while you're sitting on debt
on the other side that's right cash that
down to a th000 bucks and get it all
clean you know start throwing it at your
debt make sure you're working your debt
snowball smallest to largest balance not
R interest rate does matter make sure
you're on a written budget and in
agreement with your spouse you know
there's about eight or 10 things like
that that you do that you go through if
you say you're following us then you're
really doing it that's right you're
doing the baby steps the baby steps say
when you're in 1 through three
temporarily stop all investing while
you're in baby step two getting out of
De and while you're getting your
emergency fund built but here's the
thing all investing not just down I sort
of did I sort of follow you you can't
you're either doing your thing or you're
doing our thing okay so this stuff works
but to the but every time you dial back
one of these eight or 10 things and
don't do that you slow your butt down
well and you mess yourself care but it
just slows you down it's a prescription
when you go to the doctor and they say
you're sick here's what you need and
they write it out for you and you take
it and cash it in you don't go and
choose I'm I'm going to take that one
I'm not going to take that one you know
what don't give me that medicine give me
this one if you do that you'll get sick
and you could die you know the number I
read this the other day what book was I
reading I I guess it was Jordan
Peterson's book uh I was asking deloney
about this I couldn't believe it the
number of people that go to the doctor
and the doctor gives them a prescription
that never fill it yeah I know and then
the number of people that fill the
prescription and don't take a stinking
one of the pills man you're messing with
your health I mean so what was the point
what was the I went to the Healer to do
nothing that he said that's dumber than
crap I do not understand I hate doctors
I don't I mean I like doctors but I
don't want to go see one people die over
there I don't want to go see them but I
I mean I want to I I I but if I'm going
to go I'm going to do what the guy said
take the medicine I mean God I do not
understand yeah okay so yeah do this
stuff
exactly not because it doesn't affect me
we don't make more money if you do just
it's good for you